a vacant courtroom turned into an
archive for thousands of processed cases
but with thousands more
pending with ke's main business and
administrative districts within its
jurisdiction this court is one of
Ukraine's busiest but lacks the staff to
tackle a growing backlog of
cases we have a very heavy public burden
and we do not have adequate personnel
and Technical Support we need 100 judges
for our workload and at the moment we
only have 20 nationally Ukraine is on a
drive to recruit 2,000 new judges at the
same time trying to root out the
corruption that has long plagued the
system as an indication of just how
ingrained the problem is a recent poll
by a think tank here in Kiev suggested
that only 18% of ukrainians actually
trust their courts and a European
commission memo last year stated that
the Judiciary continues to be regarded
as one of the least credible
institutions the problem was highlighted
by the high-profile arrest of the head
of the Supreme Court earlier this year
by Ukraine's anti-corruption Watchdog
things happen Mika jikov is co-founder
of a foundation pushing for the kind of
judicial reform that will be necessary
for Ukraine to achieve its much coveted
ambition of European union membership
because we want to to go to the EU so
much we want to win the war so much that
we don't have any other option so that
is why however however difficult it is
we have to do whatever it
takes achieving that reform like
clearing the backlog of court cases is a
mountain to climb but just as Ukraine
seems transformed by its wartime
struggle for survival it might also have
found the impetus needed to achieve it
Rob McBride Al jazer
ke
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al
jazer